- On this episode we talk McDonalds
versus Burger King,
and what do I need to be doing more of?
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
- [India] McDonalds
response to Burger King.
- So that's the response right?
- The response was them just
if you wanna see the note
I can find it really quick.
I don't know if you
wanna talk about it
Sonic's a client and stuff.
We didn't engage yesterday at all with it.
This is the post.
This was their response.
I love it.
I think my idea was better.
- Jesus Christ this was really well done.
- [India] They should
have just made a day in
March called National Burger Peace Day
and made it a different thing
and not associate themselves with
a UN sanctioned holiday,
because a micro site for Burger King
- Oh, a lot of people gave
the first response that
has the most is bad
to McDonalds.
- [India] Yeah, people were
not happy at McDonalds,
but I disagree, because I think that
Burger King's micro site has nothing to do
with world peace.
75% of the micro site is dedicated
to talking about the branding.
- Well it speaks like
it speaks to people
caring about fluffy issues
not the real issues.
- [India] Yeah, and someone was like,
why can't we be light hearted?
I was like we can be
light hearted about
World Peace Day when
there's world peace.
That's how I feel.
- Look, it's also one of those issues
where you just like,
it depends on what side
of the bed you wake up on.
All of us equally don't want,
the amount of insane shit
going on in the world.
It's overwhelming for an
individual human being.
I was retired yesterday when I went
to the Bowery to start an
uprising with the homeless.
You know what I mean?
It's just
literally all night I'm like
"Why can't my chemicals switch?"
and like, will there ever be
a day when I don't wanna buy
the Jets and I wanna solve this?
Will something bad happen in my family
that makes me literally
the next day wake up
and say, that's it I'm
curing drunk driving
instead of buying the Jets,
and then also equally knowing
that way too many people
are full of shit, and are like
I care about solving drunk driving,
but don't really.
I'm like, I think that's
what my whole MO is
which is like, I like right hooks.
I need right jab, jab, jab
which is how everybody
wants to sell social media.
Which is the deeper layered thing.
Yeah, it's super interesting.
You should make this a video,
just all of this.
No, I want this to be a video in itself.
Yeah, I just really want that to be.
Oh, actually yeah, let's do it.
Here we go.
You could go black and
white on this whole thing
too and just keep it in the show DRock.
You can make the creative decison on that.
Hello everybody and welcome
to Wine Library TV,
that's where I went with it.
Keep this DRock.
Hey everybody
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this episode 134 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
That was interesting.
The brain is a very powerful device.
I really am curious how you're gonna roll
with all of this, DRock.
Back in the saddle.
A lot of people behind me today which
makes me happy, that's always good to see
the Vayner family in
full effect in August.
A lot of companies checking out right now.
Looks like the VaynerMedia crew is doing
their thing.
That makes me proud and happy.
I'm supposed to be on vacation.
I don't know what the hell I'm doing here,
and so that's that.
Excited about the show today,
appreciate everybody who jumped into
yesterday's show.
I know it came out late
so you may be seeing this
and not realize one snuck
in yesterday. You're like where's 133?
It happened.
That's it, India.
So India,
let's
- I'm just gonna let him do it today.
- Get into
the show.
- It was too good yesterday.
- Yeah you drilled it.
- [Voiceover] Tasha asks,
"Do you take on any client
"if the price is right?
"Or do you turn down based on your values
"and beliefs?"
- This has been interesting.
We've been having some
interesting situations
happening at VaynerMedia
where I would say that
East coast and West coast
political correctness bias
over certain clients has
been rearing it's head at
VaynerMedia, and I've
been really struggling
actually quite a bit lately on
what, I don't want to
be the judge and jury
of VaynerMedia's moral
compass on which clients
we take and so I'm trying
to figure out if it's
legal in America, should
that be the line in the sand?
It's a great question.
We have,
I've been, this is a really,
really tough question
and a great question.
We have passed on clients,
because of my own personal compass,
you know like the Patriots,
and
we haven't passed on the Patriots.
That's unfair to them.
Though I still hate you Patriots,
but I love Vayner Nation Patriot fans.
I just hate how you roll with football.
The answer is it's
starting to rear it's head.
America has never been more divided.
We have growing offices
in middle America which
I think will take away
some of the East coast,
West coast mentality.
Everybody in this office
is divided on things like,
should we not take sugar water?
There's plenty of people in this company
that think we shouldn't.
Guns, I mean Jesus
especially with the tragic events
of yesterday and this
entire year and just like
the last several years in America.
Alcohol.
Tobacco,
I mean what if the biggest tobacco company
came along to work with Vayner.
I think there's plent of people here
that would have a tough time working on it
would bow out, wouldn't
want me to take it on.
Is that my,
you know,
I think I made those
decisions my whole life
for me as a person.
It's easy for me.
It's me, I'm accountable to me.
I don't do the sponsored
stuff that I don't want to.
I don't do any sponsored stuff,
but I've, for example,
I've been thinking a lot
about getting a lead
sponsor for the #AskGaryVee
show in 2016, because I need
and want those dollars to apply to a lot
more advertising to
learn more about growth
of content online.
I need real dollars.
I've been thinking a lot about that,
that's interesting.
I've never thought about that before,
and never did it with Wine
Library, things of that nature.
Would I take any brand?
Absolutely not.
I think that money is the last
thing that drives me, but I also
absolutely have no interest in idealistic
over political correctness
dictating my decisions,
and I think we have that,
especially when you
live in New York, L.A.,
San Francisco, and so I
have to think of things
as collective including
a global collective
not just the United States of America.
That's my answer.
That was real.
That was real as f***.
Sorry.
I just the DRock thumb up
was pretty amazing.
- [Voiceover] Louie asks,
"What's the best way to deal
"with someone who is constantly negative
"about entrepreneurship?
And what if it's your mom?"
- Louie, I
I think the biggest way
to handle that is to
stick it to your mom.
I think you go out and you execute,
and then you tell your mom I told you so.
You were wrong mom.
You know what's great
about entrepreneurship?
The market, business, life
is it's a net net gain,
meaning at the end of the day,
either your mom's right or
you're right.
She's negative about
entrepreneurship with you.
Louie, she doesn't think you can do it.
I don't think your mom, over arching
doesn't believe that
entrepreneurship exists
or is an option.
She just doesn't believe in you.
Now, I'm drilling you right now, because
I'm trying to light a fire in your ass
to be like, really pissed,
the way I get.
Nothing excites me more
than the adrenaline
that I get.
Right now I'm fired up for you Louie.
I'm making pretend that I'm you Louie,
and I'm so god damn pissed.
I wanna literally punch
my mom in the face.
That's how I feel,
and so, but like figuratively.
I'm not condoning
violence against your mom.
My moms my favorite person on earth.
My mom is the compete opposite.
No one believed in me more
or ever will.
That being said Louie,
she doesn't not believe
in entrepreneurship.
She doesn't believe that
you're an entrepreneur.
Now the question is
back to my self-awareness
content that I've been pushing
out a lot, maybe she's right.
Maybe you're delusional.
The real question is who else in your
ecosystem does believe?
And more importantly,
forget about everybody else.
This is really the crooks
of the whole damn thing.
Do you believe?
Right, because I think one of the weird
things that has happened in my life
that I think has created the scenarios
of my existence is I have an incredible
ability.
I've had my whole life to literally
tune out every other voice except my own,
and I think that it's
equally a vulnerability.
I have no mentors for that reason.
I love my parents.
I would give them the mentor mantle,
but I really don't.
I literally just listen to my own voice,
and so if you're lucky as I am,
and I know millions of people are I'm sure
to be able to tune out everybody,
if you believe you're an entrepreneur
then you're set.
I would argue the fact
that you're even asking
me this question means
that you've put weight
into your mom's opinion,
which I think needs to be dissected by you
to begin with, because I put zero
weight into anybody's opinion about myself
because I know exactly who I am.
- [India] From B., what do you think
- B.?
- [India] B.
- Is that B-E-A?
- [India] It's just B.
- No, I know, I just wanted to say B-E-A.
Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] B. asks, what
do you think of McDonald's
response to Burger King's
Peace Mcwhopper idea?
Seems like they missed a big opportunity.
- DRock, before I answer this,
are you running the B
roll that we did before
the show?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- To start the show.
- [DRock] I can do it right now.
- No, start
start the show with it.
I think it'll be interesting.
People are gonna be,
oh, Staphon's now.
Right, Staphon.
Graduating to editing the show.
Start with all that B roll
all black and white before
it even goes into it,
because then people understand why I
screwed up the intro,
because the transition
was awkward.
I, well first of all you've seen a lot
of our banter on this.
I'm with you India.
I thought it was
I think my answer came through in the
black and white that started the show
which is
I think McDonalds,
first of all I like competitions
so I like that McDonalds kind of zing
Burger King right back.
Burger King tried to win the game
by being like, like there was a,
McDonalds was in a very tough spot.
I also love what Burger King
is doing in marketing right now.
I think they're being very clever.
Sonic is one of our great clients
at VaynerMedia.
I've got that hat on.
I think it's super fun to watch.
I think I'll answer this.
We are clearly living in interesting times
where Burger King can make a micro site
to make this annoucement,
and McDonalds official
answer is in a Facebook
post in sentence form.
If you haven't realized that communication
has changed forever in our society,
please let this be a moment where
this is how companies that
are dead heated compet,
I mean Pepsi, Coke,
like Burger King - McDonalds.
It doesn't get more than that.
I think it just depends on
what side you wanna be on.
There's the people that always wanna be on
the serious side, which McDonalds wins.
There's people that think
the world is way too serious
and you need a little humor.
I think more people sit on that other side
hence why I think the most
popular reply to McDonalds
and upvoted.
For me, for me,
I like the way they went with it,
but I can see every angle of it.
I like that Burger King did it.
I like the way McDonalds,
I just want them to fight.
Like, if you really want me,
listen, but you have to understand.
I'm giving you my answers
to me as a person.
I love competition.
I live for companies fighting
with each other and
trying to beat each other
and jockey and chess moves.
I love it, the sport of it.
Just like politics
has become a sport and entertainment
which has a lot of sad
variables around that.
I think business is about to go that way,
because everybody can communicate,
and it's all in public and all this stuff.
I'm just enjoying watching.
Pass me the popcorn.
You lost your audio?
- [DRock] Yeah. Again.
- [India] That's weird.
- [DRock] I've been
able to put that out and get
that audio.
It had full battery on this.
I don't know why it doesn't
- [Gary] So what's happening?
We're fine?
- [DRock] No, I gotta get
- Are you still rolling?
- [DRock] No.
- So there will be a lack
of a continuous screen?
- [DRock] No, no, no.
You're fine, I got it all.
- [Gary] No, but like right now there will
be some sort of pause right here.
Cool I can reference it.
- Right they'll feel a
little click right now.
- [DRock] We're gonna
go into the end here.
- We're gonna use this?
- [Staphon] I can, 'cause I have this
- Use it, use it.
Guys, you saw what happened?
Oh Stephon, you're really really
you're really earning your keep today.
You saw what happened?
Oh, I'm so pumped.
DRock didn't like last time
when we talked about
the audio breaking out
on him and he was super sad,
and we like DRock,
we did the whole thing
and see there it is,
I love it.
All captured.
Great job Staphon.
Back to this.
- Gary, out here driving in the country.
It's super beautiful.
I have a question
for you, and my
- Is he driving
and recording?
- Question
is for someone
- I'm not happy with that kid.
- Like myself who didn't grow up
learning tons of discipline like you did,
how would I go about starting to learn
the discipline that you
use to hustle and grind
the way you talk about doing all the time?
I can't seem to get myself to commit.
What do I need to start doing
to learn to discipline myself like you do?
- Two things Caleb.
First of all, three things,
please do not record while driving
ever again in your life.
Please God please.
Number two, by the way, I know some people
jump in and be like Gary, you did a car
selfie the other day.
- Yes, at a red light.
Hardcore red light and
even that's not great,
because you never know if somebody
is coming to drill you,
but where you going anyway?
Nonetheless,
two things on the discipline.
It is learned behavior.
You just have to start doing it.
It's just learned behavior.
You have to start doing it.
There's nothing else.
Now the question becomes
it's a chicken and egg game.
I think the only way
you can learn to hustle
and work this hard is
by actually loving it.
I could never do anything I don't love
at this rigor and vigor.
It's just impossible.
It's impossible,
and so figuring out what you love to do
and then just making it learned behavior.
I would tell you my team here, I know all
of them, I've watched them all in a short
period of time.
They're all faster than they used to be.
They're faster.
Learned behavior.
The speed at which my team works
even versus the way, India can probably
speak to this the best, even to the speed
that VaynerMedia works which is
every person that comes to Vayner is like
this company is fast,
but the way we work is even faster.
It's just the truth.
It's learned behavior.
You can get faster,
you can work harder,
but it's learned behavior.
The only way to really do it is
you gotta love it.
That's it. It's real simple.
It's really, that's the
answer in my opinion,
one man's point of view.
- [Voiceover] Chad asks,
"With everything that you do,
"is there anything that you
feel you need to start doing?"
- I need to start hacking
more day in and day out
time with the kids.
I've been talking about this out loud.
Where's there's smoke, there's fire.
I wish I did the show one year earlier,
because that whole year
I would have talked
about health.
The show started right as I started
taking care of my health,
so I was already in it.
You guys have been hearing me talking
about going home, taking
the bath with them,
or dinner with them.
This is me selling myself.
What I'm really good at is I keep
pounding myself into submission
when something doesn't come natural.
I need to hack more time with the kids
and they get to six and three now.
They're six and three.
Now they're really, really,
there's things, and I'm
going to the recitals
and this and that, but I want more
day in and day out time.
I've been winning on extremities.
It's worked,
but now I need to figure
out more opportunities
to spend that hour minimum a day
with them, walking to school, bath,
dinner together.
It's gonna be hard, because I'm really
a continuous guy
like start and then I just
go, breaking up the day
where I have to shut off the intensity
that I live with.
You have to understand
the speed at which my brain is activated
and the hyper sensitive nature
of how I roll when I'm in my game
when I'm, that was me putting
on a helmet on the field
which is where I start my day.
I don't stop it.
That's why I don't eat lunch.
I'm just on,
and so to stop that,
defrag, really give,
you know, so many of
you are spending hours
with your kids and loved ones,
but you're not spending real time.
Real time is mentally being in it.
Checking the box that you took your
kid to baseball practice,
but you looked at your
phone the whole time was
not being in it my friends.
I need to be in it,
and to shut that down at five PM what's
been going on for eight hours.
Give into listening, consuming, engaging,
and then restart, because
that's what's gonna happen,
is gonna be a real challenge for me,
and I need to do more of that.
Cool.
That's it right?
What's your statement of the day?
Not having this question is a lot of fun.
What's your state,
by the way the statement
is really working.
I read all the comments
on YouTube and Facebook
late last night.
I went to sleep at like
three in the morning,
and it really gave me context to
what you guys are thinking.
I'm using your feedback loops
as ways to make the show better,
but it's also really great, because
watching you guys leave
your statement of the day
versus kind of a question of the day
is there's so much more
profoud content now
in the comments section which allows
all of you to learn from each other,
and it's more community.
It's less about me.
It's more about us,
and that's where I'm going with it if you
were curious.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)